avec sa liste san siro coeur 2020 sonia
bros lance sa campagne pour les
municipales 2020 la proximité et les
changes avec les nouveaux habitants
c'est ce que veut la mer pour sa liste
divers droite on a passé les deux
derniers mandats à construire les
équipements qui était nécessaire pour
accueillir une nouvelle population
cette nouvelle population elle nous a
été imposée à la fois par la danse et la
demande de densification de l'état sur
les buts de deuxième couronne et la
vente des terrains de l'état sur la zac
charles renard les habitants de saint
cyr sont venus soutenir leur maire tout
en espérant que son programme répondent
à la demande des nouveaux arrivants de
la ville qu'elles soient à l'écouté des
saint cyriens qu'elle propose des
innovations dans la vie quotidienne
dans les rapports et des services
publics avec l'urbanisme avec la
circulation avec le cadre de vie donc on
attend vraiment
tout ça de la connaître de son héros
pour sonia bros qui occupe la mairie
depuis le début de l'année sentir doit
se développer pour devenir une ville
touristique et non une ville de
transition entre le foyer et travail
j'ai envie qu'on ait du commerce de
proximité j'ai envie qu'on ait envie de
se balader dans nos rues qu'on ait envie
d'aller admirer nos sites historiques
puisque saint cyr et quand même aux
portes de versailles et a quand même de
gros atouts et la maire sortante est
pour l'instant face à la liste saint cyr
l'école en commun qui n'a pas encore de
têtes de liste désignées